you're an inspiration to a lot of young
people so i have to ask what advice
would you give them
if they're thinking of going into
science if they're thinking of having an
impact in the world what advice would
you give them about their career
and maybe about their life thinking
about somebody in high school maybe in
undergraduate college i'd say a few
things one is this is a wonderful
profession you have an opportunity to
improve the lives of so many and do it
by having fun
the kind of play we're talking about
it's an absolute privilege
to be able to work in this kind of area
um
uh and to young people looking to say
that that have
some gifts or desired for for this area
i say please you know
go for it like do such a serious signs
broadly yeah i mean it could be it could
be i mean i'm not i don't have any gifts
in ai but like you know it could be your
buddy but you know or or in health or or
in medicine or whatever whatever your
gifts lie develop them work hard and
develop them because it's worth it it's
worth it not just um
not just because you get some status but
because the the journey is fun
and the result is
improvement to the lives of so many so i
think that that is the encouragement i
give i'd also say
if you're looking at this ugliness of
this debate that's happened over the
pandemic
i i'd say to young people we need you to
come come in and help transform it many
of the people you see in this debate
that behave poorly
i actually forgive them i've done my
best to try
um
because their act many of them are
acting out of their own sense that they
need to do good but they've but the
mistake they've made is is in in is in
this arrogance and this power but when
you come in remember that example as a
negative example and so that you when
you join the debate
you'll join it in a spirit of humility
in the spirit of trying to learn um
while keeping that that love of love
that led you to enter the field in the
first place
and yeah
choose forgiveness versus like derision
like the people that
you know have messed up like give them a
pass
because that's how
it feels like that's how improvement
starts funny i've been thinking this
it's like uh uh i told you i'm christian
right so like i thought like god has
given me many opportunities to forgive
people learn learn to practice how to do
that gave you a gift it's a very
humbling thing i guess
is there a
memory
from when you were young that was very
formative to you
so you just gave advice to some young
people is there something that stands
out to you that uh
um a decision you made an event that
happened that made you the man you are
today
i actually grew up in a relatively poor
environment like i was born in india
and i moved when i was four
my dad had uh eight brothers and sisters
uh and my mom had four brothers and
sisters
she uh grew up in the slum in calcutta
my dad his dad died when he was young
and he supported his family his kid his
brothers and sisters with the university
scholarship money
came to the u.s and my dad worked
in a mcdonald's even though he's an
electrical engineer
couldn't find a job in 1971
and so he worked at mcdonald's
um we lived in a in a uh like the this
this basically like this the housing
port like development uh in in in
cambridge this like this middle building
of the 17th floor this like housing
development
um
i mean i
i think that was transformative for me
like i didn't realize so much at the
time well how that experience of being
essentially like poor lower middle class
what effect it had on my outlook
you mentioned to me offline that you
listened to a conversation that i had uh
with my dad what what impact did your
dad have in your life what uh what
memories do you have about him he was a
rocket scientist actually
he
helped design rocket guidance systems he
died when i was 20
and i still miss him to this day
and i think that
experience of seeing him
sacrifice
his hidden self for his family
a brilliant man
but uh in many ways frustrated with like
the the his opportunities in the world
partly what led him to come to the us in
the first place
um that's uh transformed has had a
transformative effect on me and i wish i
could tell him that
looking back
you